the Star Wars Force awakens panel I know
a lot of you
there's the graphic that proves I'm not
lying I'm not a liar I know a lot of you
guys waited a long time to be here I
think like decades really and so I'm
also here to tell you that you're not
gonna be disappointed and I want you to
know before we get into this really
quickly it's not about me but I just
want you to know how special and how
emotional this is for me I am old enough
to have seen Star Wars in the theater
which is why would you cheer that it
sucks to get older but here we are my
dad took me and I stood on the sea to
completely change my life and informs
pretty much everything that came after
and of the experience is the same for
you so there's gonna be some amazing
things that are gonna happen and someday
you will look back and get to tell your
grandkids will be like shut up grandma
like shut up so I want you to really
think about this and experience it and
enjoy it as it's happening
okay because this is an experience that
just this group of us will have for the
rest of our lives so so with that I
would now like to introduce and bring
out to the stage Kathleen Kennedy a man
by the name of JJ Abrams
and mr. Lawrence Kasdan
thank you I mean I feel like they were
gonna see the movie anyway but that's
very nice of him I was on the fence
Kathy don't wanna start with you and I
want you to talk a little bit about how
I mean you know service one of the
things that helped usher in the
comic-con image so you sort of talk
about the fandom and the presence of
Star Wars throughout the years no
obviously I think a lot of people out
there know that Star Wars is 100%
dependent on the fans in this room and
all over the world since 1976 in fact in
fact when the movie was ready to come
out it was really the fans that built
the momentum around the release of new
hope so we are right back in full circle
and we want to say thank you to all of
you so just I'm like we're still a
handful of months out be able to see
this are you freaking out where are you
in production what what point we are
we're in we're editing we have a cut of
the movie we're doing we're in this
extraordinary moment where we're doing
fine-tuning and I say extraordinary
because in this business a lot of times
there are release dates before there are
scripts and to have the time and to have
Disney give us the time to do it right
is not a small thing and so we're
working hard to make the movie more what
it wants to be
mr. Kasdan yes welcome by the way I
don't think you've been to a comic-con
before have you
technically you're our dad in a weird
sort of way but can you talk a little
bit about what you guys I mean first of
all yeah you to understand about JJ is
that this he really cares about this a
lot it's as important to him as it is to
you and to me and so I want to talk
about the experience of you guys coming
together you bringing in legacy Star
Wars and then JJ you taking up the
responsibility of meeting together and
figuring out how to bring new characters
into the universe
yeah like the guy that brought me is the
genius that brings us all up here
who's George Lucas he was absolute
breakthrough monster genius and none of
us would be here I've learned for him
and he called me and said will you do
this man we started to do Empire Strikes
Back and then we did Return of the Jedi
and then 30 years passed and those
movies just like never went out of my
life for my consciousness and then Paul
came again he said will you come back
and meet these characters again 30 years
later so there wasn't even any
disjunction between my life and this
timeline and when we got JJ to say he
would do that
I went berserk because I hit about what
innovative I thought he was a funniest
most talented most perfect choice for
this movie and then he and I wound up
spending a year walking around writing
figuring it out and it's been total
gasps JJ how do you how do you push the
fandom out of the way to focus on the
work when you're working with Star Wars
is like you said it's something that is
so deeply ingrained and so important to
so many people you know I asked my mom
to make me a java costume for my 13th
Halloween and
I did the eyes but she did the costume
and it was great and I've been a fan
since I was a kid a little kid and there
is nothing normal about getting to write
a movie with Lawrence Kasdan there's
nothing normal about getting to work
with Kathleen Kennedy or to direct a
Star Wars movie i mean i sat down with
john williams to show him
scenes from a Star Wars movie he hadn't
seen yet then I directed there's nothing
normal
including this moment by the way you
guys look possible and thank you for
waiting so long to be here it's
brilliant I think I think one of these
fences or someone to watch is that you
really cede it out a lot of the stuff
and put stuff on Instagram and I know
you made this cradle base video and and
when when people started to see glimpses
of what you were building and they saw
holy crap actually they'll think these
are practical effects we're seeing like
real things in it which is astonishing
these days it's an important piece of
this and we talk about a little bit but
we did this video for UNICEF through
this group omae's and a really
successful endeavor we raised five
million dollars thanks to your help for
UNICEF innovation labs and it's a it's a
big deal but thank you for that but we
first started shooting the movie we did
this video that went out where I was
Iran in Abu Dhabi and I was standing
there and there was a creature in the in
the scene and some people there it is
and some people are starting out great
you know you made creatures nobody will
thought oh it's a CG thing and we wanted
to show you it was to CG and this is
just one of many characters we actually
brought this charity we called Papa Joe
as a nickname so let's sweep up
I ever cross their fingers cross your
fingers here we go alright so this
character this character is built by
Neal Scanlan and the creature deposit
okay yeah Neal Neal Scanlan these guys
have done an unbelievable job as you can
see does not fall off the stage how are
you don't eat that joint eat them so
this is one of hundreds of creatures
that they built for this dis film and
what's amazing is seeing the the people
who operate these things and the real
benefit of having creatures like this
you can see that character right there
you know there are there are five people
who are operating that bat creature and
a lot of these creatures are even our
background creatures that aren't even
the main event but what's so cool about
them is it gives the actor disorienting
scenes things to actually deal with
interact with play with respond to it
also helps even things like light going
light reflects on the set but on the
character so it's a big deal all these
characters use these creatures you're
seeing know in 82 because even though
we're not we decided not to use CG
the robotic technology is his really
advanced as you can see oh yeah I mean
especially this ugly for anyone who grew
up with the original Star Wars it was
part of the charm of the movie was being
able to see new characters look as
though they were had come to life but I
think CG certainly has its place but
seeing a practical effect I mean even
seeing that seeing him wiggle his nose
in that way it does something
emotionally that reminds us of the first
time we and solid Star Wars the frame
and the wall runs along the sides are
done
all right excellent and would you you
said this was a Neal Scanlan yeah yeah
Neal Scanlan and esteem them of the most
amazing creature shop and there you go
all right there we go
I mean essentially this is a when you're
working with these heads impressive
practical taxes I mean there's it's
basically just whatever limits your
imagination heads right uh but you can
say we want to build this I want to see
this I need to populate the world in
this way we use think there's there's of
course Star Wars there's gonna be a ton
of visual effects there will be there
will be CG you can't avoid it and the
important thing for us was that we make
this authentic that we tell the story
that allows the actors to interact with
and be in on a set with as much
authentic real tangible construction as
possible so sets props creatures and
adjust in health the entire process
let's go and take a couple questions for
Larry JJ Kathleen this first hello
what's your name
like I don't know what's your real name
so mr. madman
my question is for Judy Edwards and it
is what influences did you take amalgam
of concepts
did you draw upon to make this film
whether it be the comics video games
even go through first of all way to
commit JJ I couldn't really understand
you
first of all awesome costume and great
question what I think and there he could
enter this you know as well we tried to
sit down and ask ourselves what what
feels right and the only real bad day we
had was what is what delights us doesn't
mean it has to be fun all the time and
sort of you know ever silly but it means
it has to be compelling and obviously we
we treated the film's you know four five
and six especially we did those were
things that you know for me where the
film's I grew up with we treated those
as canon and by the whittendale Aaron
road it's insane to asked us to be
writing the script I start with script
with Larry Kasdan you know it's like a
hot sake obviously he can't do me at all
but we won't went to that when we don't
talk about the light we were just we're
talking about as something as simple as
a texture of a wall the fact that that
person casts a shadow creature cast a
shadow as he comes through through that
you can feel that those are real weapons
and those are real
stormtroopers back there there was a
happy moment we had been we were writing
very fast or writing very higher than
that in one month we were walking around
Santa Monica figuring out the story and
just a couple months later were sitting
in the bay of a Star Destroyer with
storm troopers drilling in front of us
and still writing of course and it was
all real it was all real and we said
well I think the answer was Batman that
we wanted to tell a story that would
that would that would make us feel and
that would be something that we feel
like the continuum of the incredible
story that the George started the
weirdest dream that is in front of 7,000
people man Batman its Martian about Star
Wars that's great that's my life thank
you very much
what is your name hello my name is Lana
grant and this is a dream come true and
so many ways so great to be here thank
you what is your question this question
is actually for JJ and Star Wars is
precious to me i sat on the couch with
my daddy when I was a little girl and we
watched Star Wars and Star Trek and
metal beyond the stars it's a precious
legacy not only to me but I'm pretty
sure to a couple of people in this room
when you get such a heavy burden and you
have this precious legacy and you have
to pay homage to that to us and the fans
and then you got this new generation
that you're building and trying to bring
this alive for them how do you approach
that no pressure no
I think honestly I feel more pressure
answering your question it's a great
question it really is now I watched Star
Wars with my parents too it was very
much even very much to me what it means
to see so many of you and I feel like
the answer that I can give you the only
answer I can say is because we we love
it and we care about it so much
our job is to not be blinded by that
meaning you can't just be a fan and then
say well you're gonna make a move
because you're a fan it's not enough
yeah I don't really stay what is it
what's the story I mean I will tell you
from personal experience when you're
directing a scene on the Linnaean Falcon
it doesn't make the scene good now it's
bitching then it's on the money about I
didn't want the scene unless if I could
make a suggestion direct scenes on the
money about but it doesn't make the
scene automatically good so you have to
ask what a literally storytelling 101
what the hair does one who are they what
makes us interesting what's not expected
how do you make this it has to be fun
and has to be scary in Aston the power
of what's come before is so infectious
or so deep that you have to harness it
but you can't be blinded by it and it's
a constant thing working you know with
Larry and with Kathy we were always
checks and balances saying that's really
cool but what does it mean you know why
we're doing this and so I hope I got to
your question by saying we will try to
rework sergeant possibly good
and I can't which to a movie also thank
you okay movie is a standalone were they
going to be with tions are they going to
be in this is going to be a serious arm
well I can't answer that because
Kathleen is the one who oversees every
possible thing well obviously with the
saga films which change is starting the
first which is the force awakens 8 and 9
will be part of that saga but we're also
making anthology films standalone movies
and Gareth Edwards actually starts
shooting in about three weeks so the
first one will go into production
that's nice thank you very much so
obviously you would made a brief
statement of a handful of days ago to
sort of let people know like you know
we're not really ready to show footage
but is there anything that you could I
mean it's yes here's the thing I really
think the truth is we we aren't ready to
show you scenes from the movie or a new
trailer and we really want to wait and
do the trailer later in the fall but the
we knew that this was too important
coming to you who care about this and
loved it so much and we wanted to bring
something that was as unique and
unexpected as we could we put together a
piece that you're going to see that we
hope would bring you into the process a
little bit of what it was like to make
this movie and get to see some of the
people who who are doing it so we have
alright so let's see this footage and I
I mean that is never-before-seen footage
of behind the scenes of the force
awakens and also like you want to find
out there was a very special guest here
in the audience
Peter Mayhew is out here there is first
Peter over there by the microphone
this is my notebook this is the notebook
that I have this is my my alright so now
we're gonna be some of the cast some of
them I know you guys I got to talk to a
little bit celebration so john boyega's
here oh yeah that's right okay how you
guys doing it's John can you talk a
little bit about your you got to walk
the floor a little bit yeah yeah and so
how is it being on both sides like you
know sort of three Star Wars now Star
Wars are you feelings that you feel any
different
being a fan I mean let's just say this
is really complicated buying a Black
Series Star Wars figure on
I can't get through the crowd honestly
it's been awesome by the way that was a
let's talk about the physical demands as
compared you've done what's what was the
what was the training element like Liam
did it change you it was like going into
acting you always hope that physically
could change yourself as well as
emotionally embody a character so to be
able to have like solid months of
training though difficult was amazing
like our incredible stunt team Oh like
the most incredible stunt team
go together a lot and then as you season
teaser we were running through a 125
degree heat and those explosions were
real
I mean don't let her to have it I just
like to thank JJ Abrams fulfilling that
would that be in the desert and make
anywhere a story well thank you Jane you
are honestly understanding amazing and I
think they look a bit hopefully play God
and hopefully my dress reveals my guns
because I work heartily Oscar Isaac home
run you so you said how was the I
believe the quote was the best freaking
pilot in the galaxy
yes did you that were you giving advice
on your piloting did anything help you
become a better pilot oh yeah you know
as an excited eager actor you know I
want to talk to Harrison about piloting
and how should I do it you know anything
special things that I should do and just
how do you work with the controls and he
said it's fake
and also it's in space so it isn't
really the same stuff doesn't apply nice
I've got it I can I can do that but you
know I think really it was taking on the
character of Bowie takes on that that
legacy not only upon but of Luke of
being these heroic pilots because if you
think about it these characters they
lived those stories that we offer
although they grew up at the same time
as those stories you know I mean Poe was
probably it was there watching and young
yarns and you know when the medal
ceremony was happening thinking I want
to be that I want to be a hero and I
want to take up that man
and and I think that's what he does you
know he even sometimes recklessly so but
yeah so it was really connecting it to
that old world it was especially great
well I want to give the fans opportunity
to ask you guys some questions so let's
let's go into the audience questions
there what is your name my name is Ryan
Ryan I'm Korean hello what's your
question
it's questions for JJ what we really
like about your Star Trek films is the
diversity of the cast we'd like to know
do you find on having any Asian
characters join the casts and any
upcoming Star Wars films first of all I
want to say go Asians feels that way
here's the thing I'm not casting the the
movies they're coming up with if I were
to I would cast them as a told the Asian
I think you mean obviously when you see
this film
there are Asians in this film so I was
involved in the casting of this movie
and there but you know honestly the the
truth is we didn't write the character
earth in to be you know any color we
didn't write character abrade to be any
color we we you know we just cast this
movie knowing that it was important that
we but we wanted the movie to look the
way the world looks and and I think it's
important that people see themselves
represented in film I think it's not a
small thing so I completely understand
and think your question is is hugely
important and it was a big consideration
but I'm really proud of the cast we
ended up with literally these actors are
extraordinary and when you're working as
long as hard as we all have on this
movie and during editing and you see the
choices you have in terms of
performances and take to take I could
not be more grateful to all you guys for
the work you did so thanks your question
around the corner here
that there is every intention to carry
on exactly what JJ is talking about in
all the Star Wars know movies that we're
going to make hi Chris my name is Monty
Boone Lane my question is for JJ JJ when
you did the previous unreleased time
piece such as lost and friends you did a
lot of transmedia and now you're doing
transmedia for Star Wars one of the
biggest ip's ever with a big expansive
universe is there anything you would do
to take away from Star Wars when you
build a new IP again in the future what
Kathy doesn't want me to say you know
this what I think I'm interested that
you use the term I read so frequently I
don't think of Star Wars as I didn't try
to answer that question I appreciate it
but the answer I could give you is this
is a story and these are characters that
we love and so I none of us I think are
thinking about thinking about it from
the outside in like that and it's weird
because you come to something like this
and you want to make everyone happy and
you want to show you something that
makes it network excited but the truth
is we're just working really hard to
make a movie and tell a story and when
things come up that we know we need to
do to sell it in market if we want that
to be as authentic as the piece itself
so I'm not quite sure what the strategy
would be but I know that if we thought
of it as an IV I think it would end up
being a very different film me me me me
you